ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه مرحبا بك دكتور خليل هل بدات تلحظ
نوعا من التراجع ولو تصيف في في الموقف
الامريكي ازاء تطورات الاحداث والحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه الى حد ما حسن هناك
بعض التحول النسبي في الموقف الامريكي على
الاقل على مستوى الخطاب يعني سمعنا قبل
ايام خطاب مهم جدا من بلينكن وزير
الخارجيه عندما كان في الهند في زياره
تحدث عن اللاءات الخمسه كما يقولون يعني
اولا لا لاحتلال قطاع غزه لا للحصار لا لا
لاقط اقتطاع جزء من غزه لا لتهجير قصر
الفلسطينيين ولا ايضا لحماس فيكاد يكون
هذا اول اطروحه امريكيه او شبه اطروحه
تتحدث ع ما لا تريده امريكا فيما يتعلق
بمستقبل قطع غزه وانا اعتقد انه هذا
التحول النسبي جاء نتيجه لعده اسباب السبب
الاول متعلق بما يعني يعني واضح جدا ان
هناك تقارير استخباراتيه امريكيه تتحدث
عنه ل ليس هناك ثقه في قدره اسرائيل على
انجاز شيء على الارض خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالهدف الكبير حول التخلص من حماس الامر
الثاني هناك تحذيرات واضحه جدا جاءت من
رئيس هيئه هيئه الاركان المشترك الامريكي
تشارلز براون قبل يومين قال بشكل واضح انه
من الصعب على اسرائيل التخلص من حماس اولا
ثانيا قال انه هذه الحرب وقتل المدنيين قد
يدفع باخرين لنضام الحماس في المستقبل
وبالتالي انت زرع الان شيء قد تحدثه في
المستقبل الامر الثالث مهم جدا قرانا في
الاخبار ان هناك بعض البرقيات او
التسريبات جاءت من بعد السفارات الامريكيه
في المنطقه سواء من عمان او من مصر او من
الاردن تتحدث على انه الانحياز الامريكي
الحالي لاسرائيل قد يؤدي الى خساره جيل
عربي كامل في المستقبل بمعنى اخر وجود
حاله من الرفض العربي لدى الشباب فيما
يتعلق الموقف الامريكي من اسرائيل
طيب يعني بعد هذا الش شرح نعود الى السؤال
المركزي كيف يمكن ان تنتهي هذه الحرب يعني
اذا كان هناك تحول او بدايه تحول في
الموقف الامريكي بدايه اي تغير في الراي
العام الغربي على الاقل على على مستوى
الجمهور
اي وفي نفس الوقت اسرائيل لم تحقق ما
تريده او تلك الاهداف التي وضعتها لهذه
الحرب الى متى يمكن ان تطول وكيف يمكن ان
تنتهي هذا سؤال مهم جدا حسني حسن ومركزي
في فرق ما بين امرين هل تستطيع امريكا ان
توقف هذه الحرب هذا سؤال السؤال الاخر هل
تريد ذلك ام لا هل تستطيع نعم تستطيع
وهناك اساليب كثيره جدا اولا لابد ان نعرف
انه امريكا تعتبر اهم داعم عسكري لاسرائيل
ليس اليوم وليس بالامس على الاقل منذ 70
سنه على الاقل ده بيسموه في في اللغه
السياسه ليفرج هناك نفوذ لامريكا على
اسرائيل هناك دعم دبلوماسي امريكي
لاسرائيل على مستوى يعني عقود مضت والان
ايضا عسكري ودعم عسكري ودعم دبلوماسي ودعم
سياسي السؤال هل تريد امريكا ذلك ام لا هل
يريد بايدن ذلك ام لا حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
هناك هذا الضغط الامريكي الذي يطالب وقف
اطلاق النار لماذا الاسباب كثيره جدا جزء
منها متعلق بمحاوله اعطاء وقت لاسرائيل كي
تقوم بالتخلص من او القضاء على حماس طبعا
هناك تعثر في هذا الهدف حتى هذه اللحظه ام
الامر الثاني هناك اهداف انتخابيه سياسيه
لبايدن وتحدثنا عنها اكثر من مره بايدن
يحاول ان يغازل كتل معينه في امريكا تلعب
دور مهم في الانتخابات القادمه الامر
الثالث الذي يحرك الامور ليس بايدن كشخص
هناك مجموعه
من المسؤولين الامريكيين اما الداعمين
لاسرائيل بشكل كامل او هم انفسهم متصهين
هؤلاء يديرون المشهد بشكل او اخر وبالتالي
ليهم مصلحه بشكل باخر في دعم اسرائيل
وبالتالي السؤال المهم متى يمكن لامريكا
ان تضغط على اسرائيل انا اعتقد يتوقف
الامر عده امور الامر الاول حجم الخسائر
المروعه للمدنيين طبعا الحجم الان كبير
جدا هناك طبعا ضغط داخلي امريكي بعد يعني
يجب ان يكون هناك اكثر هي دي المشكله ان
هناك على ما يبدو هناك فهم امريكي ان هذا
الامر ممكن تحمله حتى هذه اللحظه على
الاقل هناك طبعا ض ضغط داخلي امريكي غير
مسبوق سواء في على مستوى الشارع على مستوى
بعض المؤسسات الامريكيه الامر الثاني
عندما يتاكد بايدن انه هذه العمليه
العسكريه عمليه عمليه فاشله حتى النهايه
يعني يعني بمعنى اخر من الصعب تحقيق هدف
التخلص من حماس على الاقل في مد المنظور
ام هذا يعني انهم لابد ان يضعوا هدف
اقل من الهدف الاساسي والعمل من اجله
وايضا هنا يطرح السؤال ما هو هذا الهدف
الذي يمكن بعد الوصول اليه القول ان
اسرائيل قد حققت شيئا ما لاقناع جمهورها
بوقف هذه الحرب انا اعتقد الامر متعلق
اولا بمدى الضغط في الشرع الاسرائيلي على
حكومه نتنياهو نمره واحد نمره اثنين مدى
القدره على انجاز شيء ما في صفقه الرهائن
يعني نحد نسمع عن وجود بعض المحادثات بعض
المفاوضات طبعا متعثره بشكل او باخر هناك
حديث حول اطلاق الصراح على الاقل 80 محتجز
من الاطفال والنساء مقابل اطلاق سراح
محتجزات فلسطينيات لو تم انجا انجاز هذا
الامر قد يكون هناك بدايه لمسار سياسي ما
قد يدفع باتجاه تخفيف التصعيد ثم الدخول
في مفاوضات قد تنهي الحرب بشكل او باخر
شكرا لك دكتور خليل عناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه